I'm Coraline EDA M key and I'm here to
talk to you about a pet project of mine
called Alice before I get started by
show of hands she likes magic tricks you
wanna see a magic trick I should really
learn one that would be a great way to
kick off the presentation the years 1993
I've been diving up into BBS's
for my Atari Stacey for a couple of
years now and there's this I'm living in
Austin Texas and there's this circular
that comes out every week with just
listings of BBS's and their phone
numbers that you can dial into and one
week I pick it up and there's just ad on
the back that talks about getting on the
Internet
and I was like what is the Internet and
I was really curious about it so I
dialed in and the provider was BG a.com
and it wasn't long before I fired up
links and went to the Library of
Congress website and it was so excited
but there are no books there so I ended
up building my own website in 1993
that's the URL it doesn't exist anymore
but I'm pretty amazed that at my age I
can still remember it around the same
time I picked up an amazing
life-changing book called girdle
Eschenbach a golden braid the book was
described as a metaphorical fugue on
minds and machines in the spirit of
Lewis Carroll I was really inspired by
this book and really challenged by the
book and in fact I read that book every
decade ever since I was like in my 20s
that's word - 1995 I hit kind of a low
point in my life and I was spending more
and more time online as sort of an
escape from reality I participated a lot
of mushes for those of you too young to
remember much is since for a multi-user
shared hallucination it's coming up like
an MMORPG except it's all text-based I
ended up being Coe guide at a place
called ministry mush now a lot of much
is we're role-playing games but ministry
mush was a little different it was
simply a social environment and I kind
of went crazy creating places in
ministry mush and creating characters
and interacting with the people there
who were very cool ministry mush was
sitting on servers in West Virginia that
were actually funded by the
apartment of Defense which was really
really weird but we had a we had a
really high speed connection and we were
on some serious metal so it's kind of
cool
inspired by evolution Bach I decided to
try my hand at doing some like really
lightweight AI at the time I was
fascinated by Egypt and I was named
consider myself an amateur Egyptologist
so my first project was a bot called
budge and in a mush you could program
objects and objects could communicate
with players and also communicate with
each other but they were very limited in
the amount of data and code that they
could contain and I basically wanted to
build an expert system and so I created
a copy of the British Museum and
littered it with Egyptian artifacts and
budge was there to guide you and I
wanted people to be able to ask budge
questions like who was asked but but she
didn't have enough memory just in that
bot to contain very much information so
what I did was every artifact in the
museum became part of a database and I
wrote a protocol for these objects in
the mush to talk to each other so that
so that budge could answer simple
questions and that kind of got me
started
my next project from the mush is what I
called ghouls ghouls I realized that a
mush was the perfect environment for the
Turing test if you don't know the Turing
test is this is this sort of experiment
where you have a human operator and a
computer operator and a human subject
and then the human subject can only
communicate with the other two via
textual messages and has no idea which
person they're talking to you is a
computer in which one is a human and the
program is considered to pass the Turing
test if the human cannot distinguish
between the human operator and the
machine operator I realized the mush was
a perfect environment for this because
all of the interactions were textual so
what ghouls would do is they would
wander around the mush until they found
a location with two or more people they
would listen to the conversation for a
while and record the things that people
said that garnered a response from the
other person and they would remember
what was said they would then wander
into another part of the mush and
replay the conversation they scored
points which were considered food
pellets for every interaction that they
were able to successfully complete so if
someone responded to them they'd get a
food pellet
if someone responded to him again they'd
get another food pellet if it was
starved it would simply die if two
successful ghouls met each other they
would reproduce and their best phrases
their most successful phrases would be
passed on to their offspring fast
forward a bit 2013 my life is in an
upheaval I just had heard I needed to do
my gender transition I divorced I moved
out on my own for the first time in like
18 years and life had gotten pretty
complicated oh crap I don't see my
speaker notes one second
there we go okay well I think become
really complicated for me I become a
public figure I was speaking at
conferences around the world I was very
well known in the Ruby community and I
had created a document called the
contributor covenant which was the first
open source could have conduct in the
world which has now been adopted by over
40,000 projects this made me a target
for a lot of harassment so the internet
had become a pretty dangerous place for
me in the early days there wasn't this
idea of a federated identity in every
community you're in you could be someone
different and you can experiment and
play with your identity but with the
advent of Facebook and Google and
systems like that your identity became a
single sort of single identity across
the internet and that really changed
things so basically there was no safe
space for me so I did what any geek
would do and I started my own private
IRC channel lonely hackers Club was born
and I wrote a simple bot named Alice bot
to maintain ops and to greet newcomers
to the channel
I named her Alice after the character
for my favorite children's story around
this time I also started working on a
project called Sophia a side project
involving artificial intelligence so I
thought it might be fun to bring some of
the features of Sofia into Alice bot and
make her kind of a playground
when I move my community the slack last
year Alice came with us she had to she'd
become part of the community part of our
family
lonely hackers club has grown to about
70 participants now 70 members about a
dozen of whom are active on any given
day and Alice has grown with us and
today we're going to talk about Alice's
journey so we're gonna start with an
anatomy lesson we're gonna talk about
content and context we're gonna take a
little dungeon adventure we're gonna
have a live demo and I'm gonna talk
about what the future of Alice holds
we'll start with the anatomy lesson
Alice's written in Ruby which is a very
unusual choice for programming AI but I
told you chose Ruby because I'm highly
proficient in Ruby and I wanted to I
didn't care about performance as much as
I cared about my ability to create
features very quickly Alice comes in at
just under ten thousand lines of code
which i think is pretty good given all
that she's capable of her interface to
the outside world
is through a single route in Sinatra she
connects to slack using a ruby interface
called bossy and is connected to our
thought community with web hooks her
primary database is MongoDB [ __ ] gets a
really bad rap but I appreciate the fact
that [ __ ] is schema-less which means
that I can change my mind about my data
structures without having to worry about
migrations I was to find mongos query
syntax a lot more expressive than
traditional sequel I recently introduced
a second database to Alice a graph
database called neo4j some of the
information that alice is going to start
storing really works best in a graph
environment at the heart of Alice's
processing is the message model a
message has a trigger which is whatever
was said in a sectional it also has a
sender which is the ID of the person who
said it and finally there's the message
response which is a distinct object
that's built up by a series of
processors a message is passed through
four main processing components arranged
in a pipeline information gaining
attributes and context along the way
until a response is generated the first
of these components is the listener the
listener examines the mesh's trigger to
decide how to start processing it if the
message consists of a username in plus
plus it calls processed points
don't you say dirt in book is your
terminal front to process points
increments the targets users score and
reports their total score in ranking so
what's in red is what else would respond
with if the message starts with a number
there's a chance of scoring some points
in number Hwang who knows what number
Hwang is if you don't know what number
weighing is look it up on YouTube after
this presentation and you'll thank me
later so here's a resulting message with
its response populated that's the number
Hwang triple bonus the points gonna fail
let's rotate the board if the message
contains the word Alice is sent along
for analysis and tax processing so next
we get to the processor the processor is
pretty straightforward it determines if
the message trigger warrants response
and if so it passes it on to a component
called the commander the commander is
where things start getting complicated
the commander is responsible for parsing
the incoming message and identifying
which command and the database should be
executed to respond to it it sends the
message through two distinct partners
which are known affectionately as Bangor
and mash well gets to know these two in
just a second when the parsers do their
magic they return a command object which
commander then invokes after doing a
couple of checks some messages have an
odd have odds of actually being
triggered like number one so I might say
number one has a 1 in 20 chance of being
triggered and some commands like giving
points to someone require a cool-down
you can only give points once every 10
minutes so Bangor and mash Bangor is the
first part where bangers are simplest it
only positive messages that start with
an exclamation point like exclamation
point look which a computer scientist
would pronounce look
banger parses the message trigger to
find its nouns and verbs and looks for a
matching command sugar analysis database
mash is much more complicated if a
message sugar includes the word Alice
matched mash tries to interpret the
trigger using natural language
processing it parses the message trigger
to identify the subject predicate in
verbs and then tries again to find the
matching command in her younger years
Alice used a state machine for natural
language processing and the state
represented the progress in parsing a
sentence into his component parts the
drawback to this approach was twofold
determining part of speech turns out to
be non-trivial and she would only
understand sentences like these that
conform to a very small set of
grammatical structures natural language
processing is what PhDs call a VDP which
is jargon for a very difficult problem
in LPS and what I wanted to focus on so
I look for help it turns out that not
only is NLP of VDP there are VSPs
very smart people who specialize in
solving it some of those VSPs work for
vb C's very big corporations and they
make their work accessible through VCAs
which are very cool api's so I
integrated Google's natural language
processing API which gives me a nice
array of richly detailed art easily
crafted tokens in exchange for a humble
little sentence here's the data
structure of a token with an Associated
part of speech the token has a label and
ulema ulema is simply the word as it
would appear in a dictionary and a part
of speech has various attributes as well
so let's look at an example we say say
we have the symptoms Alice say hello to
Coraline the first token that was
returned is Alice Alice's ulema of Alice
is tagged as a noun
tagged as a subject understood as a
proper noun and a singular noun there
say which it tags as a verb labeled with
the root in the indicative mode and a
present tense hello gets the tag of X I
have no idea why
and label is discourse to is an ADP
which I found out means add positional
phrase which simply means hey this is a
proposition and finally Coraline which
is the P object Alice looks for verbs
and properties and queries a database
looking for the matching command the
trigger may be a verb such as no or an
adjective or prop prop property such as
drunk and yes you can get drunk with
Alice more about that later so this is
what a command looks like does a name
associated verbs from other indicator
words stop words so if if there's a
match but the trigger contains a stopped
word it won't trigger a cool-down period
a handler class and a method the handler
class points to a class with analysis
code base that's responsible for the
trip for triggering the response and a
particular method to use the trigger
that response and the response kind in
the case of Alice should respond with
spoken words or within emote so here's a
sample command for brew you can see the
handler classes handlers beverage and
the handler method is brew a command
includes a reference I already talked
about this the handler class and its
associated method sorry the message is
then passed to the mediator mediator is
responsible for formatting a response in
something grammatically correct and
human readable it fixing this verb
tenses it removes extra punctuation and
just generally cleans up the generated
output once the mediator is done and we
have a complete message with the
response that we can pass back to slack
through the response body to the request
that came in through the HTTP interface
content and context sometimes someone
will ask ours for information about a
topic this create the trigger is the
creation of a context a context has a
topic such as Adel Elias a corpus
keywords in an ephemeral flag the
ephemeral flag prevents a context from
going stale for example if you asked
Alice what time it is in London you
would want to cache those results so
that context would be marked as
ephemeral Alice gathers facts about a
topic by query in Wikipedia Google Evie
and Woolf
from Alfa she uses a couple of different
search techniques there's a full search
where she will search on the question as
it was written she'll do a reductivist
search where she only focuses on the
nouns that were a present in the
sentence and the other kind of search
that isn't revealed here is she'll take
the subject of the sentence like Ada
Lovelace and query facts about Ada
Lovelace facts that are returned from
these internet sources are then
calculated an algorithms applied to
determine their declarative index the
index is calculated by first determining
the position of pronouns information
verbs such as appear seems and so on and
verbs with ulema B and ranked according
to how close to the beginning of a
sentence one of these declarative
indicators appears so when you ask us
about a topic she favors facts were they
hide éclair ative index and it's not sun
shone in a snippet but Alice also
remembers what she's already said so she
won't repeat herself hopefully Doc's
waiting based on a declarative index was
the feature that I added last year
before this waiting Alice would respond
to a question like what is the square
root of pi kind of randomly there's an
impedance between the question and the
answer that she came up with this is
Alice's response after waiting this fact
has a higher declarative index and is
therefore more likely to be the response
Alice maintains the context of the last
message that she received if she's asked
a subsequent question with no obvious
topic she will assume that the context
is still current and looked for a fact
that matches key words in the query and
if she doesn't find one in the court in
the context this corpus she'll do a
subsequent search of in of Internet
sources a context cannot only refer to a
topic but it may refer to a user in the
channel in this case facts are derived
from the appropriate user model using a
predefined whitelisted list of public
attributes so in the case of Alice who
is Coraline she's going to retrieve my
bio and say Coraline is the queen of an
ever-growing world when a new context is
created it is marked as active and the
previous content is pushed down in a
stat
so Alice who's nerf Yoda nerf Galya is
just another geek in the mosh pit if a
personal pronoun is used in a question
Alice assumes that the question refers
to the user or topic associated with the
current top contacts so I can say Alice
how many points is North care to have
and she will respond if the personal
pronoun doesn't match that users
pronouns Alice pops the next content
context off the stack to look for a
match Alice is smart enough not to miss
gender people I wish humans were that
good so context allow Alice to follow
the threat of a conversation and respond
to questions in a meaningful way this is
a core feature that really contributes
to the perception of her overall
intelligence and we'll see some examples
a little later on during the
demonstration the performance one of the
fun ways that Alice can that people can
interact with alice is by exploring her
dungeon
you can look examine and pick up objects
that you find talk to NPCs and move from
room to room
everyone knows lack channels considered
part of the dungeoneering party and
moves moves together through the dungeon
so this is an example of a room and a
dungeon you were in a ridiculously small
kitchenette with a corpse in the middle
of the room and the accidents are east
and west the dungeon was generated on
the fly as it was being explored a room
is a set of x and y-coordinates it also
has an association with wonderful with
one to four door objects doors have an
Origin room and a destination room when
you use the door by traveling in a given
direction it'll connect you to an
existing room if it exists or generate a
new one and Alice on the left hand side
there that's actually an SVG map that
Alice generates on demand of the dungeon
you can access it from a browser use
exclamation point nap or map and it'll
give you a link in the current room that
Ian is highlighted in red and you can
get a description of any room including
its contents and exits by mousing over
and of course somewhere deep in the
dungeon there's a hungry GRU some people
are ageing themselves right now
if the GRU finds you and you haven't
found a weapon in the dungeon it devours
you and the dungeon is reset and as the
penalty someone in the channel is cursed
with a fruitcake just like in real life
the fruitcake cannot be eaten you also
cannot destroy it if you're just stuck
with this disgusting fruitcake
if you've ever received a fruitcake for
Christmas from Mara Trudy you'll know
the feeling and the law of conservation
of fruitcakes states that a fruitcake
cannot to be created nor destroyed
simply passed from one family member to
another the dungeon is littered with
randomly generated items people in the
channel can also forge their own items
using a forged command an item might be
a weapon a game or something readable
it can also be cursed every person in
the channel has an inventory composed
the things they found in the dungeon
items they forged themselves and
beverages that they brewed some items
are consumable some items to be wielded
in some items if their games can be
played notice in the middle here I have
them make the Tron guy sad sad merit
badge she's sorry everyone remember the
Tron guy the Tron guy hates me the Tron
guy thinks I'm this despicable social
justice warrior which isn't far from the
truth
and he actually wrote this whole
diatribe about how awful I am and how
penguicon shouldn't have invited me as a
guest of honor this year so somebody
made me the merit badge
notice that I have a game called ghost
in the graveyard so what happens if we
try to play ghost in the graveyard
this scores mean internet point so cool
I mentioned you can brew a beverage and
here's the syntax so we can say brew
Edmund Fitzgerald Alice says Alice
watches Coraline brew a decent Edmund
Fitzgerald
I wonder how Alice would describe it
robust and complex our Porter's a
bittersweet tribute to the legendary
freighters fallen crew goes well with
oysters chocolate and heartfelt balladry
for every beverage that has brewed Alice
hits the brewery db-api to see if it's
alcoholic and if so she populates this
description accordingly and if you drink
something that's alcoholic there's a
chance you'll get drunk or disoriented
when you're drunk all of Alice's
responses to your commands will be
slurred when you're disoriented you
can't make out directions very well you
can go Wes or Douglas I mentioned
readable items what happens we find a
journal somewhere in the dungeon she
describes the dungeon the journal it's
just your standard-issue issued journal
this wasn't created by anyone so she
marks the creators nobody says it might
be fun to read Reese has it and it's
currently valued at three internet
points internet points on our
incremented whenever someone tries to
steal an object from someone else the
theory is that if it's worth stealing it
must be kind of valuable it's a journal
so what happens if we try to read it
Alice pulls a random fact from our
database which may include a fact about
someone on the slack or fact from one of
her contacts now it's time for a
performance
so um fun fact when I was preparing oh
look someone's in the room with me
hi Miffy so fun fact when I was
preparing this presentation Alice's open
source I'll give you this horse in a
little bit and I ran through a demo I
would to make sure that everything
worked and I was like oh my god that
that declarative index code is so ugly
and people turn me to look in Alice's
source code and they're gonna think I'm
a horrible programmer so I completely
refactored it and I was like this is now
good this is now worth showing off and
my demo broke so I did some scrambling
to make everything work kind of at the
last minute Allison's here to cool so
can everyone see that pretty well hi
Alice hi stranger
Alice chips her hat to Coraline Alice
say hello to strange Lube Alice Hale
strange loop Alice what is a strange
loop I mentioned Ruby and I mentioned
the Internet so she's a little slow in
fetching sources so she responds with
the definition of a strangelet that's
cool
Alice oops I can't take very well I
really can't take very well Alice isn't
strange loop also a conference please
work
there we go
now we're gonna say Alice what is the
current temperature in st. Louis Wolfram
Alpha is a really interesting search
engine but its API takes six seconds to
respond so we managed to fill the gap
it's 67 degrees outside cool now I'm
gonna take a look at the dungeon when
our dining room is graffiti he's filling
out pies allies name on the wall
you notice Pippi Longstocking singing a
song about wine so let's go look at
Pippi Pippi Longstocking is that
connects developer her pockets contain
the Settlers of Catan rulebook she has
two points in his in 30 second place so
let's invite hep mom Pippi sherry shall
we
I'm gonna forge a strange loop badge
without the permission of any governing
body I'm gonna set the material a
strange loop add two laser-cut titanium
let's come in next year in case you
didn't get the announcement so let's
take a look at it you had another
example of the strange loot badge it
isn't moving that's for sure
Coraline was its creator so let's make
Pippi an honorary attendee of Strange
Loop all right now if we look at her
oops her stuff includes a stranger badge
very cool so let's play with context a
little bit Alice what do you know about
typography six seconds on the clock
maybe closer to ten typography is the
art and technique of arranging type to
make written language legible or
readable and appealing when displayed
nice Alice what is a nice font pairing
for you know the citric question how
about I can use a terrible font and
nothing pairs with it well
can do it I believe in you oh I did
misspell about thank you let's try that
again
don't make me bring up the Roku logs is
the app she's processing
Oh actually she's not what's going on up
again oh I see what's happening
sometimes she triggers on words like
nice good pleasant and so on and will
respond to say I'm really glad you're
here
or you're really a nice person so since
I said nice phone pairing she's getting
confused about what I'm asking her to do
so we're gonna move on I'm gonna try and
trick her Alice how long is a piece of
strange twice the link to the cincher
the one in Alice what do you know about
bears so right now she's building a
context she's partying at the facts he's
calculating their declarative index
she's ordering them she's storing them
in her corpus and she will hopefully
respond before I get to the end of this
very long sentence okay there she
responded Alice our bears gay
bear is a gay slang term nice oh it's
gonna be pretty quirky sometimes you say
quirky I say free-spirited I love you
anyway Ellis I love you Coraline
Alice is aware that she's an open-source
project so I can tie a bang source and
it tells you where her source code is
available we can get recent commits
maybe get a list of contributors maybe
uh we have a nasty bad
oh good you have it as rate-limiting me
right now
so thank you good hubs anyway that's how
is that's our live demo you can also
round of applause
so what does the future hold for Alice
Alice is constantly growing and changing
just like lonely hackers club is growing
and changing so remember we talked about
context and how those contexts gather
facts what if we're able to parse those
facts and answer queries about them I'm
currently working on is a house a part
of hierarchy for parsing of facts and
I'm going to give you a very ugly demo
they really need to fix proportional
fonts n-terminal I don't know why it
looks so bad because it has a part of
parsing oops no go back are you playing
play how do I make you play I swear I've
done this before
okay the cursor is blinking in my batch
typing is appearing via has a part of
parsing is very rudimentary right now
and I have a lot of work to do on a
national language processing interface
but it's looking promising so far we can
create a context called Tesla we can
wait our mandatory six to ten seconds we
get a response back and now we invoke
the is a parser and we ask for an answer
to the question is Tesla an inventor yes
that's gonna be pretty cool when that's
working also Alice currently just
repeats the facts that she finds on the
Internet verbatim from their sources
she's kind of like a college student in
that way we're all probably familiar
with Markov generators and they're
Hellspawn Twitter ebooks BOTS Markov
generators worked by examining a corpus
and generating a graph each node is a
word in each edge connecting two words
is a probability that one word follows
another
I don't want Alice to be yet another
Markov generating by so I have an idea
alice is going to select a fact to share
and build a grammatical structure using
Markov generation so rather than a
relationship in the probability between
words it'll be a probability that one
part of speech follows another per
speech and she'll use Markov chain to
generate it so it might turn out to be
so if it's noun verb a verb actually the
proposition noun she knows a fact she's
gonna map it under the grammatical
structure and say poor line is more
active at night so this will allow to
communicate facts in her own words and
using natural feel and grandma Alice
deals a lot with words and grammar but
she doesn't understand the meaning of
the words as she processes yet I
mentioned my serious ars-art project
Sofia expects this Sofia have been my
greater Dallas over time and the one I'm
most excited about is contacts not
context as Alice currently understands
them but Sofia's notion of context a
context in Sofia encapsulate sac or idea
or conscious
such as beauty or temperature or in this
case disposition a context has lexemes
which are units of meeting such as mean
rude horrible understanding
compassionate or nice these are abstract
instances of that context and they're
ranked either positive or negative as
positive expressions or negative
expressions of that idea and also given
a numeric value from 1 to 10
each lexeme can then be compared to
other lexemes in that context and we can
derive synonyms and antonyms so cold
might be a six as a negative expression
of the temperature context and Arctic
might be a negative 10 on the expression
of the center of the temperature context
and tropical might be a 9 so she would
be able to determine in that tropical
and arctic are antonyms lexemes have
forms which are grammatical expressions
of that quality working backwards from
grammatical forums we can understand how
the words and sentence relate back to a
core concept and start getting an idea
of what the sentence is actually about
we can parse a sentence like this to
determine that a subject is cat and cool
is an adjective describing that cat in
Sophia's data model cool it's both the
grammatical form meaning a word with a
part of speech and a lexeme an
expression of a core concept but a word
like cool may belong to multiple
contacts like temperature and
disposition solving for ambiguity is a
hard problem and requires parsing
sentences surrounding a given piece of
text surrounding sentences allow us to
narrow down our choices and figure out
which sense of a word applies another
interesting thing that I'm planning on
doing is deliberately mixing contacts so
that Alice can learn to pun Alice has
grown with the lonely hackers club
although she only has rudimentary AI
capable at least today
she's nonetheless fun in feature-rich
she enables interesting interactions in
our select community and is considered
by all of us to be a faithful friend and
companion her numerous bugs and
shortcomings in there are many only make
her all the more charming she's a toy
project but it ties empowers us to play
and playing is essential to learning so
to all of you I say take your crazy
ideas and go play and score yourself
some valuable Internet points this don't
call them Internet points where I may
sue you thank you
[Applause]